I really don't understand why
teachers put so much emphasis
on testing our comprehension.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today I
wanna talk about comprehension questions,
how they relate to language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Follow me on a podcast service and
if you do, please leave a review.
So comprehension questions are kind
of a staple for the language teaching
community, uh, they wanna ask you, the
teachers, did you understand who, what
did this person do to that person?
And I'm, I'm reminded of this sort of, and
I must say, I've talked about this before.
I I'm very sort of allergic
to comprehension questions.
I don't like them.
I think they're, they destroy the pleasure
of, uh, of reading or of listening.
uh, and I, the reason I raised this is
because I decided to sort of investigate
this, uh, language learning system
that the Canadian government has
spent money on, uh, working together
with the, uh, Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation and Radio Canada.
Uh, to use sort of, uh, radio program
or television programs as a means
of helping Canadians learn the other
official language, or some people
maybe need to learn them both.
I don't know.
Uh, but a key element in this
program is comprehension questions.
So I signed up, and, uh, they sort
of ask you what your level is.
And I said, this is for
French, I said, I'm advanced.
And then they, uh, give you a four
minute TV program and ask you questions
on it to sort of confirm that you
are the level that you said you
were, which I think is kind of silly.
If I say I'm advanced, it's good enough
if I'm not, uh, it doesn't really matter.
Uh, however, so comprehension
question is not really about
language, it's about trying to
remember what was in that program.
And when you listen to a four
minute television program, you're
not concentrating the whole time
so it's very possible that you will
miss whatever detail it is that they
choose to ask you a question on.
So it's actually kind of meaningless.
And it also destroys the fun
of listening and reading.
So I wanna quote to you, um, a, a
Brazilian educator, and when I was
learning Brazilian or Portuguese,
I listened to a lot of his content.
I bought, uh, CDs and he has a wonderful
voice and he has a wonderful, uh, attitude
towards learning and, uh, quote to you
in English, what he said about questions.
He said "There is a total incompatibility
between the joy of reading, a vagabond
experience, and the experience of
reading in order to answer questions
and explain what you understood."
Now, this applies both
the reading and listening.
We read and listen for pleasure.
We read and listen in order to
allow our brains to get used
to the language we're learning.
Uh, the more we listen and read the
better we learn, but of course we're
not concentrating the whole time.
Uh, there are parts that we missed
because we weren't concentrating.
There are parts that we don't simply
understand, which is also okay.
We understand 50, 60, 70 percent.
I'm never interested in answering
questions on what it is I understood.
Now again, in this, uh, it's called Mauril
M A U R I L is the name of this app.
You can find it in the, in the App Store.
Uh, and the whole thing is built
around comprehension questions.
So you can select a television program
to listen to that's either two or five
or 10 minutes long and then you answer
questions, and if you answer the questions
correctly, then you gradually can move
to the next stage, and the next stage.
So answering comprehension questions
is also means of controlling you.
So you can't just wander around
and, and, you know, study whatever
text you wanna study or whatever TV
program you wanna watch and listen to
and read, you have to kind of follow
their progression and they control you
with these comprehension questions.
And very often, you know, two or
three potential answers are correct.
Or maybe none of them really strikes
you as being correct, but you have
to fit into the answer that they're
looking for, which also bothers me.
Uh, and of course, teachers have to
prepare these comprehension questions.
So it's not just a matter, like I
can go on YouTube and find content,
uh, you know, whatever I want, uh, TV
program or a movie or, uh, documentary.
And if there are, um, subtitles, I
can import it into LingQ and study it.
Whatever I'm interested in, nobody has to
prepare comprehension questions for me.
We don't need an army of, of teachers,
you know, preparing all the stuff
everything is available to learn from.
And sometimes I understand it better
sometimes I understand it not so well.
I listen to um, Persian, uh, podcasts,
uh, read through it gradually
understand a little bit more.
And it's part of this vagabond
experience as Rubem Alvez
says of enjoying the language.
And if I had to answer comprehension
questions, um, I wouldn't, it
simply destroys the fun of it.
So I, and, and, you know, it was funny.
I, I remember when I was learning
Russian, there was a wonderful book,
uh, on Russian history and they also
had audio with it but the audio didn't
correspond to the text because somehow
it was felt that it was better.
That reading is one activity and
listening is another activity
and the two don't connect.
But to me, if I'm listening to something,
I then wanna be able to read it.
And if I read it and look at words, I will
eventually understand more and more of it.
Without having to answer
comprehension questions.
Uh, so I, you know, I raised this
because I I've, it's a kind of
a theme that I've worked before.
I really don't understand why
teachers put so much emphasis
on testing our comprehension.
Now I do understand that, uh, in school
curricula, uh, schools are, are obliged
to test the students in order to
prove to the parents and to the school
administrators that the kids learn
something, which is very unfortunate,
because as I've said before, uh, in
Canada, the majority of kids who are in
the regular French program after eight,
10 years, they can't speak French.
So it really doesn't matter how well
they did on comprehension questions.
In fact, they can't use the language.
if on the other hand, the emphasis were
more on making the language important or
interesting or fun, maybe more of them
would fall in love with the language.
More of them would learn the
language than is the case right now.
So nothing really new here.
It's just that I happen to be,
you know, uh, uh, I wanted to
test out this, this, uh, program
called, uh, Mauril, M A U R I L.
And I was immediately confronted with
all these comprehension questions.
And so I thought I would do a video.
Um, remember though, the most important
thing in language learning is enjoyment.
And if comprehension questions increase
your enjoyment of language learning
and in your enjoyment of listening
to and reading in the language, good.
For me, it doesn't.
So again, thank you for listening.
And, uh, I have a couple of
videos that are somewhat related.
So if you wanna follow up, you
can go there and have a look.
Thank you.
Bye-bye for now.